we have an update now on a cbs news
investigation you likely remember
lawyers for hertz the rental car company
will be in court today along with
customers who say the company had them
falsely arrested more than 200 people
say they were arrested charged or sent
to jail after hertz told police
they had stolen a rental car consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has more
last august colorado real estate
appraiser drew caesar and his family
were heading to mexico to celebrate his
daughter's graduation we couldn't wait
to all be together spend some time at
the beach away from all of the stress of
day to day life but at the airport
customs officers stopped him when they
checked my passport they're like mr
caesar are you aware that you have a
warrant out for your arrest out of
georgia
and at first i thought they were joking
it was no joke hertz wanted him arrested
for stealing a rental car in georgia the
previous november but caesar says he's
never been to georgia and never rented a
car from hertz he was arrested anyway i
was terrified
you know i've never been arrested before
never been in any sort of trouble i own
my own business
and
i'm sorry
it's tough
it's tough
yeah
after caesar spent over 24 hours in jail
his lawyer was able to show that on the
date hertz said the car theft occurred
he was in colorado prosecutors then
dismissed the warrant i still don't
sleep well my life will never be the
same after that day
caesar is one of 230 people who have
claims pending in bankruptcy court
accusing hertz of false arrest
the company says the vast majority of
these cases involve renters who were
many weeks or even months overdue
returning vehicles and who stopped
communicating with us well beyond the
scheduled due date they said situations
where vehicles are reported to the
authorities are very rare and happen
only after exhaustive attempts to reach
the customer but hertz wouldn't give us
the actual number of those cases and in
court told the judge it wants that
information to be kept secret from the
public cbs has gone to court to file an
objection to that saying the public has
a right to know the information this
happening to one person is too many and
i'm just hoping
that it stops so nobody else has to go
through what my family went through
hertz did not respond to our request for
comment about caesar's case now at that
hearing later this morning the judge is
expected to hear arguments about whether
hertz should be allowed to keep that
information about police reports under
seal that means secret from the public
one of those arguments as we said coming
from lawyers for cbs who will be arguing
that the public has the right to learn
what is in those documents vlad
your heart just goes out to mr cesar uh
and i thank you very much for that
reporting appreciate it